yeah once you've had your kind of first
wobbles on it it is quite easy I guess
the reason it's called a hoverboard is
it's definitely easier if you keep
moving it's a bit like a skateboard
crossword skis because as you can see
you steer with one foot or the other and
it does have that slight movement
between it I can see why they've been
selling one every 12 seconds in the
run-up to Christmas and that's why it's
the safety is such an issue and the
problem they've been with these is
actually more to do with this the bit
that I'm holding isn't it just explained
yeah so it's been the the plug sockets
that has been a problem with these
pictures here show what it looks like
when it goes wrong and there's been
quite a few examples this one exploded
in someone's bedroom while it was on
charge so what people can do if they've
already bought one of these is actually
have a look at these charges if you look
closely at that one you can see there
the british standard marking on it and
it's also encased by the right amount of
plastic showing it's got a fuse inside
but if people are concerned the advices
they need to contact the retailer inside
here there are all sorts of electrical
components as a battery that could go
wrong there's the switch when it
overheats so the ones that haven't been
made properly there is that risk we've
we bought this one at a major retailer
and from looking online there haven't
been problems with this particular brand
but people do have to be a bit careful
you have really careful how are people
supposed to know if their brand is ok I
mean it's not just from looking at the
plug yes this has got a BS british
standard on it but that doesn't
necessarily mean that this is safe it
could be a fake couldn't it yes and a
lot of these are being made quite
cheaply quite a lot of being imported
from China so we know that there have
been problems with quite a few of them
the best advice we have because there
isn't a list of brands that are a little
unsafe so the best advice we have is to
contact the person that you bought it
from the retailer and try and find out
whether there have been any safety
concerns obviously big retailers like
Amazon they have taken the step today to
pull them completely from their website
as have Argos that may be partly because
the retailer's trying to cover
themselves it doesn't necessarily mean
that if you bought it from Amazon or
from Argos that there's a problem with
that particular hoverboard and if you
want a refund you have to
return it first because there's been
some advice this morning you should get
rid of it get a refund at the same time
what's the actual yes certain have been
saying to customers just throw it away
we will refund you if you know if that's
what you want if you think there's a
safety issue we will refund you just
throw it away but I think again as with
all of these kinds of situations it's
always better to contact the people who
you bought it from and find out what
their particular policy is they're
really expensive aren't they what they
range between 200 and 500 pounds so it's
not something you're going to want to
throw away is it you're gonna have to
think long and hard about it for some
people yeah so this one cost 295 pounds
I would say that's kind of average from
the ones we've seen obviously you can
spend a lot more on them it's not a
cheap present obviously if you've bought
someone this perhaps one of your kids
this is their major present so if it's
sitting wrapped under the Christmas tree
and you're concerned about it this is an
awful thing I think for people now
having to wonder what else they could
possibly buy that would replace this in
just over a week's time yeah and also
it's not just a safety issue in terms of
the electronics people have to be aware
that there have been people who've had
accidents while they've been using them
that actually illegal to use on the
roads aren't they yes we're fine using
it in the studio that is completely
legal but we can't use them on the roads
on the pavements there was a teenage boy
who collided with a bus last week
terrible accident and he actually died
as a result they are a little bit wobbly
and getting on and off so I definitely
would suggest that anyone who's trying
it maybe do it with someone else to help
and just take it easy at the beginning
I'll be here to help you get off Harry
thank you for taking us through the
problems with these and also for
expertly demonstrating it for us thank
you